it's an extraordinary legal battles
taking place in a St Louis courtroom
this week over the future of a man who
spent most of his life in prison St
Louis circuit Attorney Kim Gardner says
Lamar Johnson was wrongfully convicted
of murder back in 1995. now Johnson who
is Now 49 years old remains in prison
because Missouri Attorney General Eric
Schmidt opposes his release 48 Hours
correspondent Aaron Moriarty has been
following this case Aaron good morning
to you good morning this is a very
concerning case usually when a
prosecutor believes he or she has put an
innocent person in prison well that
person is released not in Missouri it
has taken an act of the state
legislature and a very determined St
Louis circuit attorney to get Lamar
Johnson just his day in court
it is a hearing unlike any other the
attorneys fighting for Lamar Johnson's
release are actually special prosecutors
appointed by St Louis circuit Attorney
Kim Gardner do you believe he's innocent
I believe there's overwhelming evidence
that Mr Lamar Johnson
did not commit the crime an
investigation conducted by Gardner's
office found that evidence used against
Johnson at his 1995 trial was false and
misleading at the end of this hearing
expected to last a week prosecutors will
ask this judge to vacate his conviction
you're going to testify I will what do
you most want that judge to hear that I
didn't do this that I loved Marcus he
was a close friend of mine and I had no
reason to want to kill him
25 year old Marcus Boyd had been sitting
with another man on a porch on October
30th 1994 when two gunmen came out of an
alley and shot and killed him the man
with Boyd Greg alkene was not hit but he
told police he couldn't see their faces
it was nine at night and the assailants
were dressed in black with ski masks
like this Lamar Johnson was brought in
for questioning you know I would expect
it that they would reach the conclusion
that I didn't have anything to do with
Johnson with a history of drug
possession but no violence didn't ask
for a lawyer and agreed to a lineup view
by alkane the surviving eyewitness did
he identify you the first lineup
no the second lineup nope but shortly
afterwards Johnson was arrested for
Boyd's murder I didn't believe it I was
in
shock
ing says Johnson because the next year
at his trial the man who told police he
couldn't see the faces of the shooters
confidently identified Johnson as one of
them is there any physical evidence that
ties you to the crime nope no weapon no
clothing there that at the trial they
didn't even present a modem eight years
after Johnson's conviction elking
recanted in a 2003 affidavit Elkin
admitted that he named Johnson a trial
because he claimed detectives threatened
that if I didn't cooperate and identify
who they wanted then I must have
committed the murder
the circuit attorney's investigation
also uncovered proof in its own files
that Elkin had been paid thousands of
dollars by the state I had no idea about
that
no idea
that information according to the
Circuit attorney's investigation what's
hidden from both the defense and the
jury
yesterday Greg Elkin again testified
this time for Johnson as did this man
James B.A Howard Howard and another man
Phillip Campbell now deceased have
admitted over and over again in letters
and affidavits dating back to 1995 that
they were the two men who killed Marcus
Boyd and Howard said it again yesterday
under oath How did Marcus die
me and Philip camel killed him on his
front porch Howard is a convicted felon
serving time for a different murder
still Lindsey runnels one of Lamar
Johnson's defense attorneys says his
story makes sense he lived about 400
feet from this crime the witness
accounts and the neighbors all support
and corroborate what he is saying but
the Missouri attorney general's office
fighting to keep Johnson in prison says
a recent test revealing a trace of
gunshot residue on a jacket sees when
Johnson was first arrested tends to
prove that Johnson is guilty but it's a
bright red and black jacket not all
black as described by Witnesses
the judge will soon decide Lamar
Johnson's future in a 2021 interview for
Sunday morning he talked about all he
has lost over the last 28 years
time and uh
there's a closeness between a father and
his daughters
and I miss that
I missed being able
to be a part of their life
um
the Missouri attorney general's office
says Lamar Johnson received a fair trial
and the burden is now on him to prove
that he didn't he and his attorneys have
to convince the judge by clear and
convincing evidence that he's innocent
and that is a very high bar this
specific type of hearing has happened
only one other time in Missouri so no
one can say with certainty whether this
judge will announce Johnson's fate at
the end of this week or take some time
to issue a ruling just because I've got
to stay on this I know you are but just
a little bit that you shared with us on
this story there seems to be a lot of
evidence and shows that he wasn't there
well where was he then I was he even in
the area at the time no he was well in
the area he was three miles away that's
right there are witnesses
no I mean there's no evidence that he
was he was three miles away he was with
his girlfriend the time who testified at
a trial that she he was only out of her
sight for five minutes but then you had
a detective who testified well he could
have gotten over there and back in that
time you know so there's a real problems
why is the attorney general fighting so
hard normally isn't a prosecutor closer
to this type of case than the Attorney
General well and in this case the
prosecutor did a year-long investigation
the circuit attorney well in the in
Missouri the Attorney General's office
fights all these kind of cases just
automatically right because they believe
that you have to preserve a conviction
the Integrity of a conviction and so
that's why I've been here so many times
Missouri cases because if you overturn
it that's them admitting that they were
wrong right wouldn't accuracy be a
greater virtue than Integrity on the
past conviction well and in this case
it's the circuit attorney whose own
office she wasn't in charge then she's
saying her own office did this so she
did the investigation I would think that
that would uh I think have more weight
than the Attorney General's office that
didn't handle the trial so the man who
said I'm the one that did it did he
spend more time in jail what was that
the man who testified yesterday never
spent any time on this on another case
he did but the man who is now deceased
only got a seven year sentence and only
spent five years of that we were
invested so please come back let us know
thank you so much